- [Mark] All right, Shiann.
Shiann, where you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- [Shiann] Ohio.
- [Mark] What part of Ohio?
- [Shiann] Columbus.
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood.
Did you have both of your
parents, when you were a kid?
- No, my parents weren't around that much.
There was drugs involved.
- [Mark] You say your
parents were into drugs?
- [Shiann] Yeah and my parents still are.
My real dad recently died so,
when I was 17, I had to
find out the hard way,
but my mom's still around.
Pray to God, I wish she
would just die, but no.
Can't wish that on your mother
when that's the only person you have.
- [Mark] And how old are you now?
- I'm 20.
- [Mark] You're 20.
And how long have you
been living on the street?
- Four years.
- [Mark] Four years.
How was the rest of
your childhood if your,
your dad passed away when?
- When I was 17.
My brother had just
turned nine at the time.
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
- Pretty shitty
- [Mark] What kind of stuff went on?
- My mom let my family molest me
so she could get her drugs for free.
So I was getting raped by my
family at the age of seven.
I came down here to find out
she was trying to do it again,
so I just volunteered and
started doing it for her.
I started selling my body for her so...
- [Mark] And that's
how you make money now?
- It was. I don't do that anymore.
I usually ask for money if I need it.
- [Mark] And people help you out?
- Yeah, sometimes.
Depends on who they are.
If this piece of shit don't
care about anything but drugs,
then we'll help you out.
- [Mark] So when did you
come to West Virginia?
- When I turned 18, got out of jail.
I was in Ohio.
I got out of jail in Ohio
and I came down here.
I got tired of getting in trouble.
- [Mark] How did you
decide on West Virginia?
- My mom called me, asked
me to come down here
and I did.
- [Mark] Your mom lives here?
- Yeah. My mom lives actually
on Locus right up here,
up the road so she's pretty close by,
but just doesn't like
answering the door for me
for some reason.
- [Mark] So where do you sleep at night?
- I usually go to a bando.
- [Mark] What's that? What's a bando?
- Like abandoned house where nobody lives
but people like trashed it and left.
- [Mark] I see.
And are drugs a part of your life as well?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Which drug do you use most often?
- Heroin. meth, weed.
Anything I can get my hands on honestly.
- [Mark] Yeah. Does using drugs
kind of help you forget about
what happened as a child?
- Yeah, I run away from my problems.
People ask me why I do so much,
'cause I'm running away from my problems.
Running away from my past.
Helps me forget stuff that happens
or people that pissed
me off during the day.
Makes me feel good about everything.
Makes me not wanna kill myself.
Jump off a bridge.
(indistinct) jumped off
a bridge the other day.
- [Mark] You get suicidal sometimes?
- It's most likely all the time.
People spread rumors around
this town that aren't true,
and call somebody that's 20
years old through in life
and has a 20 year old kid
that they walk the street.
I'm never afraid to walk the streets.
I had to have five, six people
with me to walk the streets
because people have tried to
come behind me and kill me.
- [Mark] It's dangerous here?
- Yeah. Very. Like, I prayed to God
that my brother does not come down here
when he gets older, that's,
I don't want to find him dead in a ditch
from drugs or dead with
a needle out of his arm.
That's my brother.
I looked out for him that I was younger.
That's all I had to
growing up was my brother.
We had each other.
We wouldn't have parents that cared.
About drugs, yeah; about us, no.
- [Mark] So we're in a very
rural part of the country.
You can still find drugs like
heroin and crystal meth here?
- Yeah. I am finding them,
but I can find shit like that
better in Salem than I can
here in Clarksburg, honestly.
Clarksburg is so dry
because of coronavirus,
prices went up on everything.
- [Mark] But you can still find stuff?
- Yeah, in Salem.
But in Salem, I don't do
anything else other than weed.
I don't fuck with anything else.
I don't have needles.
I don't shoot up heroin.
Like the dude that I'm
living with, my boyfriend,
he told me he'd rather see me
with then anybody else here
while he's in jail, he
doesn't believe heroin.
His mom died of heroin.
She OD'd and he found
her and he's only 26.
Like he told her that he
doesn't want to talk to her
because of the fucked up shit she's doing.
And she died.
And he didn't get to say
goodbye or anything to her.
Like, I don't know how that shit feels.
I didn't get to say goodbye
to my dad, actually.
So I know how to feels.
I try to do as much drugs as I can do
to die, sometimes.
I had to be shocked six time already
because I OD'd on four buns of heroin.
By myself, I did four buns a day.
I did. I don't do that much anymore.
But I did.
- [Mark] What's the hardest part
of this lifestyle that you're living?
- Drugs, getting by,
trying to find out where
the next meal comes from.
Where you sleep at, if anybody's
going to try to kill you,
If people is giving you fake stuff
if people was ratting on
you, wearing a wire on you.
- [Mark] What's the worst thing
that's happened to you out here?
- I had a hot shot of
insulin, just insulin.
I turned gray, had to be
rushed to the hospital.
- [Mark] A hot shot is where
somebody puts something
in your drug that you don't know about?
- Yeah, but my hot shot was just insulin.
I'm not diabetic.
So it kind of about killed me.
- [Mark] And do you have children?
I have two boys already,
and one on the way.
- [Mark] Oh, you're pregnant.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] How far along are you?
- About four months, I guess to say.
I don't eat that much.
Like I have really bad eating disorder
and I get so strung out on dope
like I don't eat that much.
Like I can sit here and do dope right now
and not give two fucks.
Like fuck this, fuck that.
Like if I was thinking about my childhood,
that's all I care about.
- [Mark] Trying to forget
about your childhood?
Yeah, I run from my
problems, it helps me forget,
like, if I start thinking of
something from my childhood,
I do some drug, it helps me.
Like I forget about what I was thinking.
Like I forgot what I was thinking about.
And I'd think for hours about
what I was thinking about.
Then I finally found out
what I was thinking about
and I do drugs again.
Forget about it do again.
- [Mark] And who's raising your two kids?
- Their grandparents.
- [Mark] And your third baby on the way
will probably go to them as well?
- I'm getting ready to go to
40-day detox in Parkersburg.
As soon as I go back to Salem
and my friends can help me get in.
And after that, hopefully,
hopefully I can stay
through all this detox,
not come home in one day.
- [Mark] Have you tried
to get clean before?
- I was clean for three
months off shooting
and then everything else
before I came back to town
three days ago, I was only doing weed.
And kind of thought about
something from my past.
And people would bring it up
kinda got got involved in meth and heroin
and shooting up again.
Like in the last five seconds.
Like when you see a person
put a needle in their arm
it makes you want to do it so bad.
And I asked that person for a point,
and I shot myself up
like five or six times
and got to the point where
I didn't know where I was.
Like I was lost, I was
shaking, I was crying,
though people were trying to come kill me.
I didn't know where I was.
I woke up every night saying
somebody's at the window,
somebody's throwing stuff out the door.
And there was nobody there.
Like you get to a point where
you see, you go long Wendy's trail,
you see dead bodies for
people, killed people.
You discover heads in trash bags,
body parts everywhere.
Find it out a couple months ago
my friend died because
a drug deal gone wrong.
He wasn't supposed to be at
the place he was at the time,
and it went all wrong and they killed him.
And that person that God...
So yeah, you find dead bodies.
You find points to find heads.
You find people with hedged chopped off.
People around my age, dying.
It's hard.
Especially if you know
the person very well
your best friend gets shot
by her fricking foster dad
that loves her, that has
a freaking crush on her
that wants to be with her.
Gets shot, loses life
over something stupid.
Leaves a three-year-old daughter behind
She sees spirits, so she sees her dad
and says, mommy, daddy
said he will be okay.
You don't see that in typical child.
Typical child doesn't see their dad.
So yeah, this town's fucked up.
I'm actually getting to back to Ohio
because (indistinct)
and hopefully I can go home
after I go and try, go get help.
My foster parents, hopefully
they'll let me come back home
because I don't want to
be in this state no more.
I don't want no where near West Virginia.
I don't care where I go
as long as it's far away from here.
I don't care about going to
prison and some other countries
as long as it's far away from
here, you know what I mean?
Like this town's fucked up.
You dead bodies and shit like that.
You shouldn't have to find that
on a daily basis because people fuck up.
People wear wires on people.
Then that person finds out.
You find that person in
the river the next day.
You won't find him alive.
He's either on a river or on a trail.
I will not walk along those
trails during the day.
In the morning, at night, I don't care.
I hope he will not see me down there
unless I have a good strong muscular man
that's about this big round with me.
Somebody with knife,
a frigging (indistinct) thing,
machete, guns, something.
Like my friend had to walk
with me all day, one day
the collect drugs
because I was so scared.
And he was the only
person that had a knife.
I don't carry that stuff
with me because cops don't
really like (indistinct).
If cop pisses me off I start swinging.
- [Mark] Are their jail and prison times
that you'll get for conviction
prostitution or drug use?
- [Shiann] Actually, a
cop has bailed me out
of prostitution nine times
but that's cause my
boyfriend dosed drugs to him
like the cops around here
buy drugs, honestly, they do.
I've bought, I had chief
of police buy drugs
from me and my boyfriend like is bad.
Like they go around
every Thursday at night
at (indistinct) and give CIs,
freaking drugs out of their car.
Like it was bad.
And you see that shit and you're like,
what the fuck is going
on in this world today?
What the fuck is going on?
You know what I mean?
Like what the fuck are these cops doing?
Don't they know they could lose their job?
Oh no, we won't lose our jobs.
So no, it's okay.
We can do this.
But if they do that will
fricking arrest them,
they'll go to prison.
They'll do this.
They'll do time.
But as we can just get
away with this, cool.
Just like fricking cops are now,
white cops are now killing
black people nowadays.
Like literally I guess
the chief of police,
that after they killed
George Floyd, I guess,
he retired because he's
black cop, a black chief.
He's probably thinking,
what are these freaking
cops going to do to me?
I'm black too.
- [Mark] What's the most important lesson
you've learned here?
- The struggle's real.
Let me tell you,
my mom never taught me about
drugs until I came down here.
I had to learn by myself.
Struggle's real.
It ain't no game, it ain't
oh yeah, you can do this
you could rip me off,
You could give me a fake shit.
I don't know.
Sometime, yeah, you don't
know it's fixed shit
until you do it and you're going like this
and you're seizing.
And you fall to the floor,
or you can't stop breathing.
That's how he knows it's fake.
I woke up to Chris, slapped
me in the face, like five
six times one day because I OD'd.
I was on my back.
When you OD off heroin or
anything, you roll over
somebody rolls you on your side.
You start breathing again.
Everything's okay.
He OD'd in front of me, so
I thought I'd do it to him.
Scared the fuck out of
him like he scared me.
Like he had like five,
six cops at our house,
and walked downstairs perfectly fine,
I was like, oh, fuck no.
That's fucked up.
Like how could he come from OD
then walking down the
stairs perfectly fine?
He was like, "I didn't
think you'd show back up."
I showed back up,
knocked on his back door.
I was like, dad, I have to go see Chris.
Good luck getting them.
Ask if he's still breathing
by the time you get there.
He was like, "What do you mean?"
I was like, "It's just
a long story, fuck it."
He's like, "No, what do you mean?"
I was like, "He OD'd. That's why I'm home.
"Why do you think I came home?"
Nah, it's like you're strung
out, blah, blah, blah.
I said "I might be strung out,
"but he just OD'd, bro."
Like his sister knows how to wake him up,
like when stuff like that happens,
I never did until like somebody actually
physically told me that,
you had to run over on their side.
I was like, "He's 300 pounds,
how the fuck am I
supposed to roll him over?
I was like, I'm not that
big to help him roll over.
Every time I have him on his side
he likes to go his back.
Like he's trying to die on purpose.
His son walked in.
He's like, "Dad, why is there foam
"coming out of your mouth?"
I was like, oh, you better get him out.
You better get him out of this room now.
I was like, I'm going freaking flip.
I think you better get him out.
Like a six year old should
not have to see that.
She said, "I had to see your
dad choking on his own vomit,
"on purpose."
He was choking on his own
vomit on purpose to die.
His son comes in the next
day when I came back,
"Dad why did I see foam
come out of your mouth?
"You need to stop the stupid shit.
"You need to get off of it.
"You got to stop if you ever want us back,
"if you ever want a chance
to us nice kids back, stop.
"Why is their foam
coming out of your mouth?
"Why were you going like this?
"What were you about dying?"
I said, "No." I said, "Get him out."
I was crying.
I said, "You better get
him the fuck out, now."
I said, "If you don't
get him the fuck out,
"I swear to God I'll (indistinct)."
I felt guilt this whole family
because they let a six year old see that.
Four year old didn't
know what was happening.
He's four. He's not going to know.
He's not going to understand that.
The six year old knows a
little more than he should
because his daddy likes to run the mouth
to tell him what everybody
does in the house.
So, four year old saying
that made me flip the out.
Like my brother didn't
see that growing up.
Like he was just born.
So he kind of got lucky there.
He doesn't know who his real
mom is or who his real dad is.
I do.
I know who my hole real family is.
He doesn't.
- [Mark] Do you feel
like you may be following
in your parents' footsteps?
Yeah, I think it's,
mom did drugs.
Why not?
Like me try it.
But if I shoot up, if my
mom sees marks on my arm,
why you shooting up and
blah, blah, blah, blah.
And she's she sits there,
says, "Yeah, I've done it."
It's like, if you'd done
it, why can't I do it?
I was like, you've done it.
So why can't I do it?
You've done it too.
So you can't sit here and
judge me for what I've done.
When you do it too.
Like Chris one day, he had a point on him,
he's like, if you want to,
you can go to in bathroom
right here, that's in my mom's house.
If you want to, you can do this
shot in your mom's bathroom.
And I looked at him.
I was like, I'm not doing the
shot in my mom's bathroom.
It's disrespectful.
It's my mom's house.
That's actually my aunt's house.
That's disrespectful towards
my mom, my stepdad and my aunt
and my uncle to do like
that in their house.
I was like, I'm not doing it.
I was like your house who gives a fuck
boys don't find the needles anyway.
He's like boy's started finding their own.
Yeah, we started finding
those, picking them up.
Because Chris' sister just
leaves them all laying around,
and had some fricking big white bowl,
and had to squirt you
blood in it and dry blood.
Like it makes me throw up.
Like it disgusts me.
I didn't start drugs until I
found out my mom was hustling
in and out. Selling meth
out in and out of her house.
I asked her every day,
"Why are these people running in and out?"
She's like, "Oh, I'm
just selling them weed."
No, I found out the hard way
that she's selling them meth.
So that's what got me started.
It was payback for lying to me.
I was like, bitch it's payback.
You're going to lie to me,
I'm going to do shit
you don't want me to do.
First time I ever shot up,
she found a track mark on my neck
- [Mark] How old were you?
- Huh?
- 20.
- [Mark] You started at 20?
So just recently?
- Like recently it was
like seven months ago maybe
but I've still been 20.
She found a track mark
like the first time I was shooting up,
track mark here,
track mark there.
That's what made her flip out the most.
"What's that mark in your neck?"
Accident. I poked myself with wire.
Didn't mean to. Sorry. My bad.
She said, "No, no, no,
there's bruises there too.
"It's big, thick, like you
accidentally missed a shot."
I was like, "I don't know
what you're talking about.
"I don't shoot up. I don't
know what you talk about."
You shot up, blah, blah, blah.
I was like I didn't do it in my neck
I had someone else do it for me.
She like, "It's Chris, it's Chris."
I'm not telling you the names.
I won't tell you who
helps me with my stuff.
It's none of your business.
It's like you told on
me, you ratted me out.
On a frigging recording
and made me go to jail.
I'm not mentioning names around you.
I don't tell her where I'm at.
When I'm somewhere, she has fine me.
I tell her, I'll meet her halfway.
I will not let her know what house I'm at.
Whose house I'm at.
I say I'll meet you halfway.
I'll meet you half way.
You'll see me halfway there.
I was like, if you piss me off, bro,
I'm not showing up.
Like one day on my birthday
all she cared about is getting drugs.
- [Mark] All right, Shiann.
Well, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- You're welcome.
- [Mark] And good luck with your baby.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Good luck with rehab, too.
- Yeah. See how that goes.
- [Mark] Thank you.